I
[Music]
hi everyone I'm Steve Brenton and I've
been thinking a lot about the
coronavirus Cove it 19 I know a lot of
you have too
this is affecting all of us and I've
been thinking a lot about whether or not
I should kind of jump in with any
educational material about about the
coronavirus and to be honest I've been
very hesitant I have no medical degrees
not a doctor and the last thing I want
to do is mislead anyone all of my
degrees are in mathematics and
engineering but the more that I think
about this this is a curve we've all
seen this is the flatten the curve
picture and the more that I think about
it this whole idea of flattening the
curve is really a control problem okay
so what I really want to do is think
about kovat 19 and flattening the curve
specifically as a control problem or
from the lens of control theory and so
you know I want to start off at the very
outset with a caveat no one should make
decisions based on what I'm gonna talk
about here you should not be used for
policy decisions I'm gonna get numbers
wrong I am NOT going to give any
recommendations about what anyone should
do but I have decided to make a short
sequence of videos essentially thinking
about Kovan 19 and controlling or
flattening the curve from the lens of
control theory and the reason I'm doing
this is because I think that there is a
lot that we can learn from this
perspective of control theory and how we
control complex systems in fact this
system exemplifies many of the most kind
of interesting and challenging aspects
that control Theory deals with and has
dealt with for decades okay and so I
think that there's some value at least
in thinking about this from a controls
perspective what is the impact of delays
in your measurements or imperfect models
what are some strategies for controlling
these types of systems okay so I have
decided to make this series and now I'm
on a mission to kind of educate as many
people as possible
about control theory and I have for a
while and if you want to help please
you know subscribe you can also follow
updates on Twitter a taiga and Steve and
share this with people ok so I want to
talk about this is kind of the overview
video and I'm gonna go into depth in
some of these topics in in follow-up
videos but to kind of oversimplify the
disease system one of the things we're
really really concerned with or one of
the outcomes that we want to model is
the the rate of infections over time ok
so this is a curve that many many of you
have seen this kind of exponential
growth so as a disease enters a
population and starts to spread it
starts off spreading exponentially at
some point that exponential growth ends
because there's no more people or
there's less people that are susceptible
to being reinfected or infected and then
that eventually tapers off but the big
concern is that if this this kind of
infection rate is larger than the
capacity of our healthcare system then
there are huge huge problems and so the
chances of people dying goes way up and
also this this puts a lot of other
people at risk who are already
vulnerable if the health care system is
overtaxed then a lot of vulnerable and
sick people are gonna suffer because of
this and so kind of the the strategy
that a lot of people have been have been
talking about is this idea that we want
to control the system through some
actions to you know flatten this curve
to be below the healthcare capacity and
it's necessarily going to stretch it out
and at our disposal there's lots and
lots of things we can do and I'm not you
know this is not exhausted this is just
a cartoon okay so we've already done a
lot of these we've closed shops and
restaurants limited lots and lots of
travel cancelled conferences we don't
have you know shake hands anymore
we're also you know we
it's also recommended that you are
facemasks there's a lot of medical
research people are working hard on
vaccines which would be you know a big
control knob and there's also this this
educational piece and that's what I'm
hoping to help with is you know
understanding how this works and how the
system works and how control works
actually makes the control more
effective I think that's a really really
important point is that knowledge about
this system actually makes these
controllers more effective good
leadership makes these controllers more
effective that's critical and I'll point
out in a lot of the control theory I
talked about you have this control
algorithm in this case we are all part
of this control algorithm every human
every government every company we are
all part of the controller we're a part
of this algorithm and our actions are
you know are what makes or breaks the
system ok and also I want to point out
that you know there's this this idea of
flattening the curve there are other
aspects of the cost function of the
optimization that you know world leaders
and business leaders are trying to
optimize this is a complex multi
objective optimization we don't want the
economy to completely collapse we don't
want people to die and max there's big
serious issues that this control problem
you know has to bear on so that's what
I'm going to talk about ok so I always
abstract things a little bit to just you
know you have some system that you want
to control and your controller is going
to actuate or affect the system and
there will be some outcome so after you
do your actuation and there will be some
outcome and so in this case our setpoint
is essentially what we want that disease
curve to look like we want to flatten
that curve so we set some some curve and
we're going to try to predict some
control actions that would get us there
okay and in the diagram I've drawn here
this essentially relies entirely on
forecasting our model of the system we
use a model of what we think the system
is going to do to cook up a controller
to get us to where we want to be and for
those of you who know anything about
control theory you know that this is
kind of problematic okay if we're not
actually measuring what the system is
doing and feeding that back to our
controller we're not going to be able to
do that good of a job okay
so this kind of a control strategy
relies on a very good model of our
system and I think you know really good
epidemiological models are hard to come
by these are tough tough systems this
kind of control is not robust to
uncertainties so there will be
uncertainties in our model there will be
things we can't measure there will be
you know things that are outside of our
control parameters will change the model
will change in time as the seasons
change as people's actions change all
kinds of uncertainty in this system and
it's very hard for this controller to
handle those uncertainties when you're
not measuring and feeding back the
system okay and so you know obviously
the system is going to have disturbances
and things changing it over time so the
strategy that you would normally take in
a control system is to measure as much
as you can about what your system is
doing and use that measurement as a
feedback signal to update your
controller on whether or not it's
actually doing the job that you want it
to be doing okay and you know this is
one of the things that stands out to me
in all of this is in some cases in some
countries there are you know really good
measurement networks so for example in
East Asia you know years ago there were
the SARS scare people were really afraid
that SARS was going to do what kovat is
doing now and so after that there was a
lot of surveillance infrastructure that
was put into place so that you could
take you know really good measurements
of the system a lot of detective work
going and finding the sick people and
then tracing who they talked to and
going and kind of searching through the
network to measure what's actually
happening in your system and on the
other hand there's a lot of countries
where we just are not measuring enough
of the system for whatever reason to get
this feedback signal that we really
really need okay but I can't stress
enough the importance of feedback and
in your system of course those
measurements are going to have noise of
course they're not perfect but what
feedback allows you to do is especially
compensate for uncertainties in your
model so even with a relatively poor
model with uncertainties with
disturbances with noisy measurements
measuring your system and feeding it
back can have a huge impact on your
ability to control even very complex
non-linear HIDA mention 'old I am
excited about this particular control
problem is the issue of time delays so I
talk a lot about time delays in my
control bootcamp and we've known for a
long time that if there are time delays
in any of the stages of this control
system that has a really negative impact
on how well we can control the system
how robust our control is what kind of
performance we can get how effectively
we can we can achieve this setpoint and
how fast and responsive ly okay and
that's really worrisome because there
are lots of time delays in the system we
know that there you know there is an
incubation period in the virus it takes
time for symptoms to show up it takes
time for this to spread to other people
the measurements take time it takes time
to run a test and see if someone
actually has the virus when you enact a
new control lot it takes time for that
to go through chains of command and
actually get into you know the minds of
all of us and to actually be an
effective control strategy and so those
time delays really worry me a lot
because I know from a control standpoint
how sensitive control problems are when
you have big time delays and so just one
strategy when you have time two ways is
to use a model based controller
basically you use the model of your
system to cook up the best plan you can
predicting the future and then you have
a slower feedback controller that
actually measures how your system is
doing and feeds that back to slowly
correct and so this is kind of a one-two
punch of a fast model based controller
and a slower kind of supervisory fee
that controller based on the
measurements of your system and as far
as I know this is kind of the best
strategy we have for controlling systems
that have big time delays where you have
model uncertainties but where you really
do need robust performance as soon as
possible as quick as possible so I think
this is really relevant to kind of
understanding strategies for you know
flattening the curve and and effectively
controlling this situation okay so in
this series I'm going to zoom into
different parts of this control problem
okay so so this is kind of how I view
the world this is massively
oversimplified again please don't use
this for actually making decisions just
use this for understanding how to
control systems in general so we are
going to zoom in on modeling the disease
system itself so we're going to talk
about you know agent based models
Network dynamical systems high
dimensional nonlinear models si our
models and again none of these models
are going to be perfect I don't believe
a perfect disease model exists and one
of the things I want to stress is that
even imperfect models can be very useful
in this feedback architecture okay so so
we need to not just completely throw
away models just because they're not
good control theory actually gives us a
formal way of controlling systems when
we know that we have imperfect models
okay that is what control theory does
we're also going to zoom in on what
types of measurements we can take how
time delays will affect the system kind
of just general issues with sensing a
complex high dimensional networks
dynamical system with time delays this
has a huge impact on the effectiveness
of our control
we will also talk about the control
strategies themselves I'm going to in
particular talk about model predictive
control and I've done in videos on this
in the past really model predictive
control is very close to what
governments are actually doing right now
based on you know forecasting where they
think the world is going to be in a
month or two months or however
and then you know making a control
decision and then seeing did this
actually go the way we thought it would
do we need to make more or less
aggressive control decisions so model
predictive control is going to be a very
very useful way of thinking about how to
control a system that has imperfect
models and these timed Elise and
especially you know in control problems
usually there's a limit to how much you
can do like your controller can't do
everything you can't go force every
person to do everything you want them to
do and so model predictive control also
deals with limits and saturations on the
controller on the actions you can take
on the dynamics themselves and so it's a
very very useful perspective to be
thinking about these control problems
okay so that's what we're gonna be
talking about is understanding just kind
of the spread of infectious diseases in
a complex high dimensional networks
dynamical system like humans on planet
earth from the perspective of control
theory now I guess kind of one other
point I want to make is that you know
implicit in all of this I've said this
so many times before control theory is
really applied optimization where you're
trying to shape the response of your
system that you're trying to control
through some control strategy and the
optimization problem here is really
delicate you are literally talking about
human lives the global economy there's
all kinds of real you know stake here in
this optimization problem and so
defining the cost function that is a
moral issue that's that's not something
that any one of us can do that's a real
problem is defining that cost function
this stresses the importance of
leadership and education we have to know
what we're talking about and we have to
have leaders that lead and that actually
help us shape that cost function and
effectively build these control
strategies and we need to listen to the
models we need to listen to the experts
this is this is very important so what I
hope to kind of convey to you through
this series
is the importance of modeling even
though they're imperfect and kind of
what is the flavor and texture of some
of these models you know why do we get
exponential growth why does it saturate
how does this spread on networks I want
to give you a flavor for how you would
sense systems and the importance of
latency and time delays control
strategies and then kind of this bigger
picture of infrastructure on sensors and
actuators you know ideally we'd have a
lot of these sensing situations
surveillance systems in place already
and so that's that's something I also
want to talk about is just kind of
control design from the ground up how
would you build a system that was as
robust to an epidemic as possible okay
so that's all coming again I you know
really feel passionately about educating
people in control theory and I hope that
that you learn something from this all
right thank you